the only thing we can be short of about
the future is it will be absolutely
fantastic welcome to this episode of in
to the impossible from the arthur c
clarke center for human imagination at
the University of California San Diego
in this episode UCSD physics professor
Bryan Keating interviews professor and
author Matthew Stanley professor Stanley
teaches and researches the history and
philosophy of science at NYU's Gallatin
school of individualized study he holds
degrees in astronomy religion physics
and the history of science and is
interested in the connections between
science and the wider culture he's the
author of Einstein's wor how relativity
triumphed amid the vicious nationalism
of World War one the story of how
pacifism and friendship led to a
scientific revolution and now into the
impossible today it's my pleasure to
welcome my friend and fellow physicist
seeker of scientific knowledge and
wisdom and things beyond professor
Matthew Stanley of New York University
on the arthur c clarke centers into the
impossible podcast which is a production
of the arthur c clarke center we've been
having having such events and podcasts
for the last few years now and I invited
everybody to check us out on the
imagination that you see STW you today
want to learn from my friend and
colleague about his newest contribution
to scientific literature and popular
scientific literature and also talk a
little bit about his endeavors in
popularization of science namely his
best-selling podcast which is called
lucky if and I want to get into that
later towards the end we were for our
listeners to you
obtaining more information about you so
first of all welcome Matt and
congratulations on the upcoming release
of Einstein's war well thank you very
much it's a pleasure to be here so we've
known each other for a few years now
you've been to visit here and and La
Jolla and said Diego and I've left that
up with you in New York I want to just
give a brief taste maybe an
advertisement not that my you need this
but for why the program that you run an
independent sort of Studies program that
you were on or helped to run and NYU is
so special and while its mission is
fulfill that sure so our unit of NYU is
called the Gallatin school of
individualized study and what we do is
provide a space for students who have
things they want to pursue and study
that don't fit in well to traditional
disciplinary structures so sometimes
that means students who are interested
in multiple things that they want to
find some way to bring together so for
instance I've had students who opted
study physics and philosophy yeah and
then other research students we have are
ones who want to study something that
doesn't quite fit anywhere so for
instance who's interested in the nature
of consciousness so they'll need to know
some philosophy and neuroscience and
psychology but none of those departments
are quite right so those students come
here and they work really closely with
us as advisors and then they get to take
classes everywhere in the university and
we teach them how to think in this sort
of interdisciplinary and innovative way
to pursue their own interests and how
how long have you been affiliated with
that program eleven years now I think
and but your training is as a physicist
right it's that's right so I started off
in physics and astrophysics I built
lasers and then got interested in the
humanities kind of by accident and
discovered slowly that
while I was really interested in science
the sort of questions I was interested
in science weren't ones that I could
really answer in the lab but rather I
needed to kind of change my point of
view and that's when I discovered that
such as such a thing as history of
science existed and that's where I've
been spending most of my professional
time lately
and when we first met back I think it
was 2016 we you were at that point
engaged sort of in the in your endeavors
related to your current book which is
about Einstein nationalism and World War
one and if I recall you we're starting
to flesh out those ideas as long ago as
then maybe before so maybe you can talk
to me about what made you inspired
you've written about science and
religion before this book is completely
different from that and I thought it was
a delightful read amongst you know I've
been asked to read three or four books
this year and you'll explain why for the
audience why this year 2019 is so
significant both in the history of
science and particularly I'm Stein
studies almost an industry and to itself
can you talk a little bit about what how
this book differs from your previous
books maybe talk about your first your
first books and then and then we'll
segue into Einstein's war sure so my
first two books were academic books so
written for a small audience on specific
topics and the particular issues I was
interested in or as you as you say
science and religion and I was
particularly interested in this question
of how it is that an individual
scientist could hold their own religious
beliefs and practice their faith and
still be sort of productive scientists
that so I wanted to because that's a
that's a dichotomy that a lot of people
think of is very difficult if not
impossible so I was curious how that
actually worked
so my first book was about this guy
Arthur Eddington it was a Quaker
astronomer and he's an important part of
Einstein's story as we'll probably talk
about in a bit
so he's a deeply religious but also
extremely liberal and modern and highly
scientific so I was interested in kind
of how that played out in his work what
he's best known for today is events he
did almost exactly a hundred years ago
now let's see here we're 15 days shy of
a hundred years when there was a solar
eclipse and he went to this little
island off the west coast of Africa to
test the prediction that Einstein had
made which was that the gravity of the
Sun could bend light and this was going
to be a definitive test of Einstein's
theory or general relativity and this
the general structure of the story is
fairly fairly well known it appears in
textbooks and so on and this is sort of
the moment that makes Einstein as we
know him that is he's he's an obscure
German physicist that very few people
had heard of and then almost overnight
as these results get announced he
becomes the most famous person in the
world
but one of the things I found
interesting as I was researching
Eddington was realizing how much of this
story was bound up in World War one so
as this happens right after the end of
the war it's actually before the formal
peace is declared so the guns have
stopped but German you still under
blockade so I was really fascinated to
see how much of the story of Einstein
becoming famous was tied up with these
political questions during the war and
so it's no strain I'm famous of course
no stranger to politics even in his
early career he was sort of targeted for
semi radical views during the you know
following the his miracle year where he
discovered the so-called special theory
of relativity leads to the most famous
equation in physics which is equals
mc-squared
but he really didn't achieve the
worldwide fame and he certainly didn't
receive the international recognition
for one reason or another until after
these events right that are described in
this book
you sort of maybe speculate on why this
is and and maybe talk about the
fortunate turn of events that for
Einstein in retrospective that led to
him he basically receiving this
attention whereas if he had been if the
eclipse had occurred a couple of years
earlier that he possibly would not have
or did occur a couple of years earlier
but the expedition failed for reasons
that I'd like you to get into but maybe
speculate on what alternative history
counterfactual is you show often often
like yeah so it's it's kind of a funny
thing to think about world war one is
being fortunate for anyone but it
certainly was for Einstein so so
Einstein and as you say he's been hidden
working on relativity since 1905 but it
isn't until 1915 that he finishes
general relativity sort of his magnum
opus and we might think that this would
have been sort of an extraordinary
moment for world science but in fact
almost no one knows about it partially
this is because Einstein just isn't a
very important person but more important
is that Germany is under blockade
because of the war so the Royal Navy is
preventing any ships from coming or
going to Germany and then there's the
trenches on land so scientists had
stopped sending scientific
communications back and forth between
enemy countries so essentially other
than Einstein's friends in Berlin very
few people even know he has finished
this theory so what should have been
this experiment moment is sort of this
tiny little quiet thing and what happens
is that Einstein as you mentioned is no
stranger to politics and he's a
socialist and he's on the political left
and he's under a lot of pressure for
that within Germany so he's a pacifist
bring a halt for the war but he's deeply
uncomfortable being in the German
capital as the war is raging so he
cultivates some friends in the
Netherlands which is a neutral country
during the war so he finds other
like-minded physicists
these are people like hae lorentz Valon
de sitter paul ehrenfest so Einstein
goes to this little town Leiden in in
the Netherlands and that becomes sort of
a center for the study of general
relativity in large part because
Einstein s friends are there these are
people he's he's happy to sit around
with and play the violin and talk
politics as well as talk physics and so
one of those folks
Valon de sitter decides that more people
should know about Einstein's new theory
of general relativity so he sends a
letter to London with sort of a capsule
summary of this new theory and it gets
opened by this one person Arthur
Eddington who's really important for two
is really important that he's the one
who opens that letter for two reasons
the first is that he's one of the few
people who can read non Euclidean
geometry right which is the format in
which Einstein's theory is written and
second and more importantly because he's
a Quaker he is a pacifist so he thinks
the war is terrible and he's very
excited to the opportunity to sort of
create this english german connection
through science literally over the
trenches of the war
so Eddington takes up sort of the cause
of Einstein and relativity both because
of its scientific importance and because
it's sort of an opportunity for him to
show how science can transcend sort of
the worldly strife of the war mmm and so
it becomes sort of a respite from that
so you look back on a series of events
that had to occur in order for
relativity to get tested when it did a
hundred years ago it was also there was
an opportunity that Einstein had to and
he agitated for to have his theory
tested you know sort of the 1914 Eclipse
and that ultimately proved unsuccessful
even though I think technologically it
would have been important I do you know
I was an experimental astrophysicist I
would like to talk to you about some of
the notable controversies or
controversies perhaps as Eddington might
say that's around even the
interpretation of the results to this
day but
but there's a yeah there's another
serendipitous fortuitous event which
took place which was essentially the the
the World War one again it's another
write the actual events World War one
that led up to before you know preceding
the 1919 so there were accident yes yeah
right and so at 1912 sort of an early
version of general relativity Einstein
had realized that there would be
described it a tional deflection of
light and he had a number he was looking
for it's about 0.8 arc seconds and so
based on that as soon as he gets his a
job in Berlin actually he manages to to
get friends like Max Planck to conjure
up the money to pay for an expedition to
go observe to look for this prediction
at the 1940s 1914 eclipse which happened
to be in Crimea which was part of Russia
at the debt at the time so a friend of
his a friend of Einstein's a young man
named Irvin Freund lectures in charge of
the expedition and they go out and they
set up their equipment and I should say
there's a number of expeditions there
that's you know solar eclipses are rare
enough that everybody sends teams when
they can and they were days away from
the Eclipse when the war breaks out and
all of a sudden foreign look and friends
are no longer German scientists setting
up their telescopes they now look like
enemy spies setting up surveillance
equipment near a major Russian naval
base so they're all arrested as spies
their equipment is impounded foreign
Lick is actually released miraculously
and one of the first prisoner of war
exchanges of the conflict and Einstein
of course is devastated because you sort
of laid everything on this measurement
right this is how he's going to convince
people that relativity is right and then
about a year later he discovers that he
had made an error in his calculations
and the deflection is not about point
eight arc seconds it's about one point
seven so it's this great irony that
if the war had not happened then foreign
Lick would have done the observation and
been looking for the wrong number so if
you had done the observation well that
would have been seen as evidence not for
relativity right so Einstein has a
number of extremely lucky that ends
during the course of the war so one of
the things that really stood out to me I
don't know if you had an opportunity to
view the total solar eclipse of 2017 the
so-called Great American Clips I did for
my dome
yeah yeah so I was on the East Coast and
you were closer to the west coast and
when I was observing this first of all
it was very difficult to get my you know
then four year old of the car to even
witness it because he was kind of grumpy
him they want to get out why is he
getting dark in the middle of the day I
got him out and that he was going crazy
it was this you know quasi religious
experience and you know for him and kind
of this this aw sense of awe and
vastness of the universe but when I was
witnessing it I was sort of overcome
with a different type of curiosity which
was I don't see any stars that are even
you know possibly not yeah
reach of the of the clip now there's
another piece of fortuitous happenstance
if you will some say you know x-files
would say nothing is a coincidence right
but but if you look at where the eclipse
took place celestially in that in the
1919 eclipse it took place in a very
rich field of background stars and the
Hyades cluster yeah
and had it been observed 1940 or 1912 I
guess 1914 it would have been a much
poorer background probably closer to the
background that's it was seen in 2017
from the US hey so I wonder you know
when when that eclipse took place I I
did
I must confess I was you know looking at
the corona and that but I I saw you know
maybe one star with the naked eye and
then you think well that's you know
nowadays you know we have CCD cameras
even you know the degree of
technological sophistication currently I
have one student who I would trust with
a solar expedition to take an optical
picture you know and they did and got
many many views of this picture but but
there were no stars and so he talked a
little he talked a lot in the book about
the about the logistical links to which
astronomers had to go you know
international travel over months and
time and I have to say you know it still
boggles the mind and and for that reason
hopefully we can get into some of the
doubts that may be still persist and I
think that they're more well placed and
say you know doubts that the earth is a
sphere or or that Sun you know doesn't
go around the earth etc so I wonder yeah
if you can talk a little bit about the
I'm a physicist in a former you know
recovering and what do you what do you
make of the technological so I just say
it's a it's a fantastical treasure meant
to do for a whole bunch of different
reasons and as you suggest the 1919
eclipse was very fortunate for a number
of physical reasons right so one of them
it was red in front of the Hyades so
you've got a nice cluster of bright
stars that you can look for it was high
in the sky and when you're looking for
precise measurements a little little
less atmosphere to go through counts for
a lot and it was six minutes long which
is really long for the total solar
eclipse so they were able to take lots
of good photographs and those conditions
just don't happen very often and
Eddington actually talks about this one
when making the case for the expedition
back in 1917 in 1918 he says we will
have to wait three hundred years until
conditions are this good again so like
let's get it right this first time in
terms of stellar visibility this is was
a real struggle for on Steinman
Eddington and everybody at the time so
as you say they're hard to see with the
naked eye particularly if the eclipses
close towards the horizon because the
slightest bit of atmospheric distortion
ruins it and it also depends enormous
Leon the state of the corona so if the
corona happens to be expansive and
bright in that quadrant of the sky then
it'll wash out any stars you can see in
terms of photographs the equipment that
you usually use to take a good
photograph of the corona or of a solar
eclipse is not good for picking up on
small images like stars that is used a
different optical setup so this is one
of Einstein's early problems so early on
when he realizes there should be a
deflection his first thought is not
let's go send an expedition because
that's really hard to do and you have to
wait for an eclipse but let's just look
at old eclipsed photographs and see if
we can see the deflection there so he
writes to all the astronomers he knows
and they write till they all astronomers
today now the query actually gets all
the way to Mountain Wilson and nobody
has any good star photographs and the
reason for that it's just because nobody
cared right that's not what you look for
it's not while you set up your optical
equipment to try and record so there
were a few kind of accidental captures
of stellar images and that's how they
ended up deciding what telescopes they
should bring so they ended up bringing
not the kind of photograph not the kind
of telescopes you would normally use for
a solar eclipse observation but an Astra
graphic which is what you use for fine
stellar measurements at the time and I
just threw one of the things that came
up a lot and so it comes up a lot too is
the the scale of the measurement right
so 1.7 arc seconds comes out to be about
one sixtieth of the millimeter on a
photographic plate and depending on your
field of technical expertise that might
seem absurdly small how can you how can
you reliably measure one sixtieth of a
millimeter and the astronomers at the
time sort of shrugged their shoulders
and say we do this every day right
that's the that's a pretty big stellar
relax and we can measure though as
fantastically precisely so for
astronomers they've been doing this for
decades and it's kind of interesting to
see the the skepticism from even like
experimental physicists you say one
sixtieth of a millimeter is far too
small to measure and the astronomers say
it's no big deal
yeah the thing that struck me is that
they also had to take images when the
Sun is on the other side of the of the
of the constellations of the zodiac in
this case and that they hadn't preserved
those plates also under pretty
controlled conditions I mean this wasn't
you know you download it to your laptop
and and click on a couple boxes and even
nowadays it's not as I say it's really
not so easy there are a lot of
subtleties and measuring star positions
and it's you know left as an advanced
you know kind of exam topic almost for
advanced undergraduates at least to - to
actually try to do this with the CCD and
maybe even show you cannot do it with
certain CCD cameras most CCD cameras or
not most telescopes are nameless but
then that as I say is with a telescope
not a piece of film and emulsion and
that has to be preserved and kept over
you know six months or more years before
and it was just remarkable how fast how
soon after the Eclipse the results were
published of course a great fanfare and
he talked a lot about this in the book
is sort of this early version of you
know kind of social media or social
proof that really by virtue of the
abstractness of the of the underlying
physics served to make Einstein a
celebrity and perhaps you know really
amplify his advocacy for for things such
as political views so wonder you know is
this in your mind I mean have there been
other examples where you know kind of
science and politics so so directly
intersected both either for good or for
bad I mean later on Einstein would
advocate for atomic weapons and and he
would use the pain I think that he had
gleaned from this episode but how often
has science and politics you know really
been intertwined in this way
almost always I think is sort of the
answer surely as as the world gets more
globalized in say the middle of the 19th
century the issues are more significant
just because information can be spread
more rapidly but simple things like the
metric system for instance or where the
zero degree of longitude is which
nowadays we think of as as fairly
trivial were unbelievably politically
fraught conditions so for a very long
period of for instance there were two
zero degree longitudes right there was
one that went through Greenwich and
there was one that went through Paris
and which one you chose depended on your
national Allegiance
so if you were in the United States say
you had to choose right were you were
you on the French side or are you on the
British side and those had quite
extraordinary consequences and talked a
little bit about the you know kind of
shift in worldview that was ushered in
after the Eclipse so you know one of the
more remarkable aspects of Einstein's
theory of general relativity so Einstein
had two theories that both have the name
relativity in it and the theory of
general relativity subsumes the theory
of special relativity and which as I
said earlier it deals with the
interrelationship between matter mass
and energy equals mc-squared
the constancy of the speed of light
aspects of bizarre aspects that are
completely unfamiliar to our everyday
life such as length contraction and time
dilation none of which we ever perceive
and our human beings don't perceive but
but then general relativity which
subsumed special relativity actually you
know in some sense is more easily
interacted with on one hand and then of
course much more abstractly related
another so in my mind there are aspects
of relativity which are really simple
and you do a beautiful job explaining in
the book such as the principle of
equivalence
which are another form of relativity and
I should say that the term relativity or
the concept of relative motion of
objects goes back to Galileo and
probably before but he was the first to
really champion it in the famous
dialogue and to world systems he talks
about a boat in motion and then inside
the boat where he can't see the outside
ocean as you're moving you know birds
will fly around and bugs will fly around
and they have relative additive
velocities with respect to the water and
so on well Einstein turned that on his
head when he said that the speed of
light was constant and so forth but you
talk a lot in the book about the
principle of equivalence which in some
sense you know is as revolutionary as
the constancy of the speed of light and
I wonder was that taken as you know the
scientific canon you know before I mean
that doesn't depend on the Eclipse being
right or even the you know curvature of
space-time being warped by a matter that
we'll get into but none of that depended
on so is there any you know was that
taken for granted or was that really
kind of controversial the equivalence so
the equivalence principles I think
fascinating episode particularly in
history relativity but also in the
history of science generally in that
it's extremely accessible yeah so you
can do the major convincing of the
problems principal equivalents just
sitting in your chair right now you just
have to kind of think differently about
watching things fall and think about how
you feel things it was not a major thing
unless you or someone like Einstein and
specifically someone like Einstein you
subscribed to the work of Ernst Mach who
is a late 19th century physicist and
philosopher and Mach had sort of a
philosophical perspective on science
that's nowadays called positivism and
the stress of maquis and positivism is
put on a direct measurement that is any
category and any kind of scientific
ideas or categories you have you should
track back to how you directly
physically measure it and experience it
and it's that kind of mocking thing
that gives rise to special relativity in
1905 so the equivalence principle is
sort of an extension of that kind of
thinking but not many people were
thinking that way I think is one of the
things that really makes Einstein
distinctive is he has this kind of
critical approach to the categories of
science so when he's wondering about
gravity he doesn't his first thought is
not to write down a new equation or set
up a laboratory experiment because he's
a Mach Ian he says how do I feel gravity
how do I know that gravity is pulling on
me right now
so people who were interested in those
sorts of philosophical questions about
science were very impressed by the
equivalence principle everybody else
said that's fine but come back to me
when you have an experiment we can do
right and of course it's very difficult
to do experiments when you require
masses on the order of the Sun or you
know much much greater masses but as you
point out in the book you know it is
sort of still pertinent effects of
general relativity in addition to purely
sort of philosophical and going back to
Galileo etc they are at work in your
pocket the fact that the that the local
space and time interrelationship is
affected by that mass is built into
every cell phone you know that has a GPS
receiver within it because without those
Corrections that are due to fundamental
general relativistic properties of
space-time curvature we have matter with
associated with it we would not be able
to navigate in anywhere I'm not able to
navigate super I've told you before I
got off the you know the the voice of
navigation my car so I don't have to
women yelling at me that I can't drive
which is which is usually true when I'm
with my wife
I put the but the you know the notion
that it's you know somehow esoteric or
you know bait you know just just pie in
the sky literally I think is is really
you make a beautiful case how how it
really affected not not only science you
know and for scientists but actually
eventually the general
as well yeah so the applications is the
general relativity which as you say
nowadays is we're literally surrounded
by take a long time in even sort of
applications within science it isn't
until well after World War two that
people are applying in to things like
cosmology on a regular basis so before
that the impact of relativity is sort of
purely philosophical and social you know
nobody has a GPS in their pocket in 1919
but what they do have is a worldview
that had just been shattered by the war
idea that had been four years of
industrialized slaughter on the kind of
scale that no human being had ever seen
before people were doubting everything
this was also the era of the Russian
Revolution so when people talk for
instance when people at the time talked
about a revolution in science they were
thinking about a revolution in political
terms right they were thinking about
governments being overthrown and
societies shattered so that's sort of
the the framework that people are
thinking about relativity in so Einstein
kind of as a word becomes shorthand for
any kind of upset hierarchy and
destroyed order and inverted ways of
thinking about the world and so he's
both sort of simultaneously this great
icon of hope and peace and
internationalism but also sort of a
threat to what everyone thought they had
already knew known about the world
and I think it's that kind of pull in
two directions that really brings
Einstein to the fore and makes the
average person care about him even
though they don't understand the science
at all yeah you mentioned the milieu in
which he was involved and of course one
of the great philosophers of the day
Karl Popper was also kind of opining at
that time in an attempt I believe to you
know sort of replicate what girdle
eventually would do for mathematics
which is you know improving in
completeness a crisp test to define you
know what is mathematical it is not
mathematical and then of course popper
come
up with his falsification ISM I think
you call it in the book criterion which
is which is maybe something you can get
into and and and I'd like to discuss
with you how it's made a resurgence in
some fields including my own which is
the investigation of the multi-verse and
by tuning and all sorts of things so can
you explain what it was Karl poppers
obsession with falsification and maybe
how did it intertwine with politics back
then because he was a jerk yeah so this
is an interesting kind of side element
of the story so karl popper's a young
man he's I think 17 when the when
Einstein becomes famous so he's Austrian
he's too young to have fought in the war
but he's very interested in science and
he's a Marxist and this is important for
a couple of reasons so one of the things
that Marxist at least at the time made
the case for was that Marxist philosophy
sort of predicted a certain series of
political and economic developments in
the world that as capitalism would would
collapse onto itself and then Marxist
societies would appear from from the
ashes of that and one of the things
popper found was that any event that
happened in the world would be seized as
evidence that Marx was correct so on one
hand that's super powerful right every
revolution every war is that well that's
just what Marx would have predicted but
he was sort of unsatisfied with that and
at the same time Freudian style
psychoanalysis was becoming popular as
well and that had a similar feature
which is there are rules for
interpreting dreams and any dream you
have a Freudian can explain to you in
Freudian terms what that dream meant so
again very powerful but popper was was
sort of unsatisfied he was he was
worried that these theories were too
powerful that is if you could always
find evidence to support your ideas
wasn't that some kind of problem
so that Einstein comes along and what
he's impressed with by Einstein was that
Einstein liked to say not just if there
is gravitational dejenne
then relativity is true but he liked to
say it as if there is no gravitational
deflection relativity is not true and
popper said you know that's what science
must be that is the the willingness to
be proved wrong because with both the
Marc system psychoanalysts there was no
observation that would convince them
they were wrong so so popper uses the
example of the 1919 Eclipse as sort of
the perfect example of science
you put a bold theory out there and
explain how it can be wrong so as
anybody can be right it's very easy to
massage information to make it look like
you're correct it's much more risky and
therefore more impressive he says to set
out the ways you could be proven wrong
so this is you say this comes to be
called falsification isms idea that the
essence of science is not proving an
idea right but proving bad ideas wrong
and then eventually you're just kind of
left behind with the the best
explanation that has survived all the
tests so far and I should say this is
not this is a very handy way of thinking
about science because it's fairly easy
to sort things and to falsifiable
hypotheses and non-forcible falsifiable
hypotheses and the reason it becomes it
gets this resurgence in the 1960s is
actually as part of an attempt to fight
back against what nowadays we call
pseudoscience sort of the emergence of
creation science and Velikovsky ISM and
erich von daniken style you know fringe
scientific ideas so actually it's people
like Carl Sagan and friends who pick up
popper as a useful tool for saying these
things are just not these ideas are not
scientific as well and as usage as
nowadays it's become important again in
cosmology I think largely due to the the
many-worlds hypothesis and many and some
people suggest inflation as well and
then of course string theory
so the question being what are the
observations that can prove those ideas
wrong that is are they falsifiable in
poppers sense and and one of the I think
the the fact that it turns out it's
actually not so easy to apply poppers
ideas
did you sorts of things that is we have
vigorous arguments about whether
multiple universe theories are
falsifiable or not and this is one of I
think the difficulties with poppers
theory is that it looks like it should
be easy to apply but in practice it
turns out to be quite difficult yeah and
as I often like to point out you know
two of the things that that popper
you know derided as non-scientific or
unfalsifiable were astrology and you
know Marxist you know dialectic
materialism and you know if you look at
your local newspaper you'll find you
know you know astrology is alive and
well and he can I was not going in on
any time of day or night and Marxist
socialist you know though many more
countries that are you know Marxist
socialist though that still endure to
this to this very day than popper could
ever have dreamed of what was so you
know kind of interesting to me is how
yes it has researched in this
description of you know what is what is
real what is real science especially
with regard as you say string theory and
and and the concomitant potentiality of
multi versus and inflation I want to
just close in the limited time we have
left with one and just as a nerding out
opportunity with with a great sage like
yourself the you know the eclipse was
sort of very it had all the great
elements have had a great story it had a
literal cosmic event you know it's not
something like the you know the LHC
turns on it runs for a couple years it
collects five data points you know that
are not ruled out by some other man then
the Higgs boson is there and there's a
probability of one in three million
that's that's weak but this had the Sun
you know being eclipsed by the moon
these are things that were you know
foretold omens back in the pack it just
had all the great and and risky events
that had almost proven fatal and in
certain cases and so it had had this
wonderful power of authority and story
and and all these biases built into it I
think a lot of people feel the
scientists are not susceptible to biases
I personally do think I don't have bias
your answer but you know it take for you
know with the grain of dust
you know what level of authority I am
but but what do you think about this
notion that scientists are so this an
infallible on unforseen that you know we
don't have aren't subject to biases you
often hear that well religious people
you know just believe in stuff based on
faith but scientist is always based on
stories based on reason and etc what do
you where do you stand in that in this
discussion so I think it's actually
quite dangerous to think of science as a
perfect purely rational system of
producing knowledge and this is what I
mean by that is that that's what we're
taught in you know elementary school but
that's not the case and it's not hard to
find examples in which scientists are
real people right they have political
beliefs and religious ideals and they
have friends and they have enemies and
they make mistakes and they have flashes
at inside right and if you think that if
you're sort of raised on the idea that
science is by definition is a purely
rational entirely empirical enterprise
the first time you encounter one of
those real people situations your faith
in science is easily broken and this is
something I see with my students a lot
that build the first time they they just
stay here you know Jim Watson saying
something sexist and racist they say oh
well scientists aren't perfect after all
why should I believe any of them but if
you accept right from the start that
science is a distinctly human Enterprise
full of the messiness and desires and
beliefs then then I think not only is it
much more robust against those sorts of
criticisms but I think it's also much
more
right if you if you sewed for the story
in my book if you think Einstein just
sat down one day and wrote out the
equations of general relativity and then
somebody just went out and proved it
that's a very uninteresting version of
science right and I think would be hard
to get people excited about going into
science if that was the kind of thing it
was but if you point out that Einstein
is trying to keep himself from starving
to death at the time and has to talk is
where a past border guards at the Swiss
border crossings and Eddington is trying
to keep himself out of prison for being
a pacifist at the same time he's trying
to set up this globe-spanning expedition
it seems to me that that's a much more
compelling kind of industry to join up
with right a place where you can really
ask cosmic questions and meet
interesting people and draw on all of
your skills right it's important to be
creative and social and insightful along
with being good at math and knowing how
to tighten the micrometer screw right
yeah it always troubles me when people
say oh I'm not a scientist and you know
no one would ever say I don't know
English you know I'm not very otherwise
educated people obviously so it was
really truly a delight speaking with you
today and I can't thank you enough for
your time and I sharing the excitement
not the least of which because I am
actually mentioned in the back of your
book which I just I am very happy to to
take that a little bit of credit that I
might have earned along the way so it's
great to hitch a wagon to a star like
yourself so I want you to just spend the
last couple minutes maybe talking about
where people can find you the book any
websites and then just a minute about
your podcast with Phil Schoen
sure so the book is Einsteins war it's
available for pre-order on Amazon now
I'm not sure when this will be airing
but the book is officially out on May
21st it's available
in hardback and ebook and audiobook for
which I did the narration too so if you
have been able to stand my voice for the
last hour or so then you should do that
my email is Matt dot Stanley at NYU dot
edu if you want to drop me a line but
otherwise my public face is through the
what the if podcast that's what the if
comm which I co-host with my friend
Phillip Shane a documentary filmmaker
where we change something about the
universe and try to figure out what the
consequences that are sort of half
popular science half science fiction
improv yes it's really truly a
delightful podcast I've been lucky
enough to go on it a couple times and
hope to be on it again and have you back
on the arthur c-- clark center for the
human imaginations into the impossible
podcast this has been production of the
arthur c clarke center at UC san diego
and I want to thank you congratulate you
and wish you the best of luck Matt with
all your future endeavors especially
this wonderful book Einsteins war thank
you so much I'm really appreciative
being here happy to come back anytime
thanks